- So wait, is it true
that so you and Scott
y'all added to your
family during lockdown?
- Yes we did,
do you want to see this person?
- Yes, because I have a golden doodle.
- Oh, you do?
- Yes.
- Wait, I want to see.
- He was, he was just here a minute ago,
(whistling)
come here, come here, come here.
Oh my gosh.
- Oh my gosh, he's huge.
- He was supposed to be a miniature,
hi, he was supposed to be
a miniature, but he's not.
He's like 40 pounds.
(laughing)
His name is Henry.
(gasping)
Stop it!
Oh my God.
- He was,
I woke him up and he's sleeping.
- Does he have puppy breath?
- Yes.
- Aw.
- If puppy breath means
horrible, horrible breath
like mine, then yes.
- In the morning, yeah.
No, I it's so funny.
So how big is your
golden doodle gonna get?
Is that a miniature or normal?
Like a regular.
- It's normal, it's normal.
His parents are,
you know, like 50 to 60 pounds.
- Well, this one was
supposed to be 15 to 18,
lies and deception,
you're about 40,
but he is the sweet,
golden doodles or so,
so I, the reason why I went
for it is 'cause we have,
oh my God.
I used to hold him like a baby.
- He's so cute.
- Now I can't.
Yeah, they're the best, right?
Especially in quarantine
- Yeah.
- 'cause it tends to be super depressing.
- And I only have like,
I, it's not that bad.
I only have like five nannies for him.
Can you, can you,
(laughing)
can you come in?
See watch I just do this.
Can you just, thank you so much.
- One feeds, hello?
One, one feeds, one walks,
one naps with.
I love your five nannies.